probably should have waited a little
little bit longer after lunch so here's
Eric's top tip don't eat and then try
this
I am Noah I this is your 3 minute boot
camp upper-body workout so today we are
going to be doing a boot camp style
upper body workout Noah I don't know
what you're doing there I don't know
it's like some Tarzan and stuff but walk
me through it we're actually gonna be
doing all right so we're gonna do
everything from the waist up we're gonna
hit it all especially focus on that back
so let's get into the first move we're
gonna go close grip push-ups for this
one we're gonna add a reach in with it
to target the lats in the back
rhomboids tap that chest on the floor
full range of motion we're gonna bring
it up one reach now we're going to
pyramid this next time to reach okay all
the way up
one minute let's see how many you can do
so when you're saying pyramid we do one
push-up just one push up push ups reach
reach do leading we're green four five
all the way up however high you can get
in that one minute second move we're
gonna hit we're gonna have to go
overhead over grab some weights any form
of resistance is gonna count milk jugs
with quarters or pennies that you can
literally grab anything so we're gonna
hit a curl to a neutral grip press
bringing it in to a tricep extension and
back down the same way then for the last
move what we're gonna do we're going to
hit a push-up renegade row so push-up
draw that way to your hip draw that way
to your hip now some people have hand
problems their wrists get sore so what
you can do is you can actually do that
pushup grab one weight but when you come
up we're going to jump those feet up
we're gonna grab those weights again now
this is really important because this is
taxing on your lower back so we're gonna
straighten our legs straighten our legs
keeping our back nice and tight we're
gonna keep that butt out keep our back
nice and flat not rounded and we're
going to hit a neutral grip row then we
just bring it back down
I chew it up you knock him down let's go
get it start it up
go get it let's get a big reach in there
I really want you to reach out like
you're stretching through that lap what
are you up to me how many pushups you up
to six come on this is when you grow
when your body's tired this is where you
grow the most right here and time we're
going right into it no delay press bring
it down keeping those elbows in nice and
tight self perfect try to bring it down
a little slower be very robotic with it
so what we want to do here is we want to
see how many we can get under that
minute now if you start finding yourself
suffering with that form stop the
overhead press just take it to that curl
perfect tries getting a little tired
good it's a wrap on that there you go
core is working back is firing remember
make sure on that bro that the butt is
back feet are about hip-width apart
you're really staying strong in that
back I don't want you to get sloppy
there right there that's when you heard
something break it up baby we're done
the recap guys we started this boot camp
upper body workout with close grip
push-ups going into those reaches and
pyramiding each set a minute worth of
that we then went to hammer curls to the
shoulder press back to the tricep
extension a minute worth of that then
hopped on over to the renegade row to a
findt over row and get a minute of that
that gives you three minutes that gives
you your total boot camp upper-body
workout make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any other fighting
weight episodes
you